بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي عهد المملكه العربيه السعوديه رئيس
مجلس الوزراء اصحاب الجلاله
ان يرحب بكم في مصر هنا في مدينه شرم
الشيخ التي تستضيف قمه تنفيذ تعهدات
المناخ كما تستضيف على مدار اسبوعين
القادمين الدوره 27 لمؤتمر اطراف اتفاقيه
الامم المتحده الايطاليه
والتي نتطلع ان تخرج بنتائج شامله وقويه
تساهم في تعزيز عمل المناخ العالمي على
كافه المستويات
والحقيقه انه عندما طرحها عليه عهد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه رئيس مجلس
الوزراء منذ بدعه اشهر فكر فكره عقد القمه
الثانيه لمبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر هنا
في شرم الشيخ بالتزاوج مع قمه المناخ وكان
فاعلياتها فلقد رايت انها ستعد فرصه
مواتيه لتصفيه المزيد من الضوء على هذه
المبادره المهمه التي اتى اطلاقها منذ نحو
عام من اليوم
ليعالج احد الجوانب الضروريه في عمل
المناخ في عالمنا العربي وفي منطقه الشرق
الاوسط التي تعاني اكثر من غيرها من
الاثار السلبيه لتغير المناخ على جوده
الاراضي الزراعيه وخصوبه التربه فضلا عن
ارتفاع المطارد في درجات الحراره ونظره
المياه والجفاف
ولعل العدد الكبير من الدول التي انضمت
الى المبادره منذ اطلاقها اللي هو دليل
على الجديه التي تليها دولنا في المنطقه
العربيه لجهود مواجهه تغير المناخ سواء
على صعيد خط الانبعاثات والتحول طاقه
المتجدده او على صعيد اتخاذ اجراءات فعاله
للتكيف مع الاثار السلبيه لتغير المناخ
وهم جانبان يمثلان جوهر هذه المبادره ففي
مصر على سبيل المثال استطاعنا القيام
بخطوات واسعه في اطار التحول نحو الطاقه
المتجدده سواء طاقه الشمسيه او الرياح او
الهيدروجين ونقوم في الوقت الراهب بتدشين
مشروعات طموحه في مجال النقل النظيف وعلى
صعيد التكيف استطاع مصر تحقيق نجاحات
ملموسه في الاداره المستدامه للموارد
المائيه وتضمن الوثيقه مساهماتها وطنيا
المحدثه وفقا لاتفاق باريس عددا من
الاهداف الطموحه للتكيف في قطاعات الزراعه
وحمايه المناطق الساحليه والتنميه
الحضاريه
ومستوى الامر في مصر تقوم سعر دول منطقتنا
العربيه بغزل جهود مشابهه في هذا الاطار
ولعل استضافه منطقتنا لمؤتمر اطراف تغير
المناخ العام الرائد في مصر والعام القادم
في دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده الشقيقه
وخير دليل على الدور الذي بات الدولنا
تطلع به على صعيد عمل المناخ العالمي
والتزامها بتنفيذ ترعه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم رغم
التحديات الاقتصاديه التي تواجهكها في
الدول العالم حاليا والطورات السياسيه
الدوليه اتصال بالاسباب في اوكرانيا وغير
ذلك من تحديات فان مؤتمرنا اليوم يمثل
فرصه سامحه لالتفاف قرض دول العالم
وقيادات القطاعات الاقتصاديه وكليات
مؤسسات التمليل التمويل الدوليه وغيرهم من
الشركاء في هذا الجهد حول هدف المشترك
داخل عليه الا وهو ميت التحرك العاجل
والناجز والفعال للتصدي للتحدي
المناخ
فالكل يدرك ان الوقت ليس في صالحنا وان
الفجوات في خفض الانبعاثات وفي اجراءات
التكيف وتوفير اليات ووسائل التنفيذ وعلى
راسها تمويل مناخ تحتاج الى تعامل سريع
والى اجراءات تنفيذيه على ارض الواقع ومن
هنا فاننا على ثقه ان كافه المشاركين في
مؤتمرنا هذا العام بشرم الشيخ في كل حجم
المسؤوليه الملقاه على عتيقون وحجم توقعات
التي تعول مجتمعتنا في كل مكان على الوفاء
بها من خلال مخرجات هذا المؤتمر
ومن جنبنا كرياسه لمؤتمر الاعتراف اننا لم
ندخل جهدا في توفير كل متطلبات عقد
المؤتمر تنزاميا واجريا وبما يقفل اوسع
مشاركه ممكنه لكل الاطراف الحكوميه وغير
الحكوميه كما مازالنا ولا نزال كل الجهد
تقريبا جاءت النظر حول جميع القضايا
الموضوعيه الخلافيه لتيسير توصل الاطراف
المختلفه لنقطه التقاء وتوافق تسمح بخروج
المؤتمر بمخرجات عمليه الفعاله ترضي
الطموحات وتستجيب لتوقعات الشعوب في كل
بقاع الارض
اتصال بما تقدم واتساق مع مع حرست مصر على
تاكيده من ان الوقت قد حال للانتقال الى
مرحله التنفيذ على ارض الواقع فان مبادره
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر تمثل فرصه ممتازه
لتعزيز التعامل بين اعضائها من الدول بهدف
حشد المزيد من الاستثمارات وتوفير اليات
جديده للتمويل المبتكر لدعم المشروعات
التي تقوم بها دولنا لمواجهه تغير المناخ
بالتوثيق مؤسسه تمويل
العربيات التي تطلع بدون مهم في هذا
الاطار
كما تمثل مبادره اطار مناسبا لتعزيز
التعاون التقني والربط بين مراكز الابحاث
في الدول الاعضاء لتحقيق التكامل بين
البرامج البحثيه والتطبيقيه المتعلقه
بتكنولوجيا مواجهه تغير المناخ
ومن هذا المنطلقه فانني ادعوكم اليوم خلال
اجتماعنا هذا الى طرح افكارا افكاري
مبتكره ومقترحات بداله تساهم في تعزيز عمل
المناخ في دول الينا في سياق مبدا التنفيذ
الذي نجتمع في اطاره وانني لعلى ثقه انما
سيخرج عن اجتماعنا اليوم من نتائج سيعبر
عن استمرار التزامنا بعمل المناخ على كافه
المستويات لصالح الاجيال القادمه في
المنطقه العربيه وفي العالم
اشكركم وتوقف الشكر مره اخرى الى اخي سمو
ولي العهد رئيس الوزراء وتطلع الى نقاش
مثمر وفعاله
[تصفيق]
شكرا فخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي على
كلمته
اعطي الكلمه الان لصاحب سمو الشيخ مشعل
الصباح ولي عهد دوله الكويت فليتفضل سمو
مشكورا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
فخامه الاخ
عبد الفتاح السيسي حفظه الله رئيس جمهوريه
مصر العربيه الشقيقه
صاحب السمو الملكي
الاخ الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ال سعود حفظه الله ولي العهد ورئيس مجلس
الوزراء بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه
اصحاب الفخامه والسمو والمعالي الحضور
الكريم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يسرني في البدايه ان انقل لكم تحياتي امير
دوله الكويت
سمو الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح حفظه
الله ورعاه
وتمنياتي سموه لكم بالتوفيق والنجاح
للوصول الى الاهداف المنشوده
لمبادره الشرق الاوسط للاخضر بدقيقتها
الاولى والثانيه
ويسرني في مستهل كلمه ان ارفع اسم ايات
الشكر والعرفان
الى حكومه جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
لما لمسناهم من حفاوه الاستقبال
وكرم الضيافه
والاعداد المميز للدوره 27
لمؤتمر الاطراف
لاتفاقيه الامم المتحده
الايطاليه المعنيه بتغيير المناخ
كما اغتنمو هذه المناسبه لاتقدم بخالص
الشكر والتقدير
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه على
اطلاقها النسخه الثانيه من قمه مبادره
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
تزامنا مع انعقاد مؤتمر الاطراف
ال 27
لاتفاقيه الامم المتحده
الايطاليه لتغيير المناخ حيث تعتبر هذه
المبادره نقطه تحول هامه لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط في العمل المناقي
واساسا
للتعاون الاقليمي في مكافحه اثار التغيير
المناخ وهو ما يعبر عن
الرغبه الصادقه لدولنا الاقليميه في تنفيذ
بنود اتفاق باريس للمناخ وتحقيق اهداف
ومؤشرات
التنميه المستدامه 20 30
اصحاب الفخامه والسمو والمعالي
ان دوله الكويت تؤكد التزامها بالقرارات
والمبادرات الخليجيه والاقليميه والدوليه
المعنيه بالبيئه
فقد تضمنت رؤيه الكويت جديده 2020
ركيزه اساسيه محورها بيئه معيشيه مستدامه
تسعى من خلالها الى تحقيق الاستدامه
البيئيه
ولفاء بتعد بتعهداتها البيئيه امام
المجتمع الدولي
كما ان دوله الكويت ملتزمه
بكافه معايير التعاون مع الامم المتحده في
تنفيذ مشاريها البيئيه المخصص لها
وفي هذا الصدر
فقد شرعت دوله الكويت في تنفيذ عدد من
المشاريع
مثل مشروع الوقود البيئي
ومصفاه الزور العالميه
ومشروع من اوله الكبريت ومشروع خط الخط
الغاز الخامس
اصحاب الفخامه والسمو والمعاني لا شك ان
مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
باشراف اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد
بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود حفظه الله
تحقق الكثير من التطلعات البيئيه على
المستويين الاقليمي والدولي من خلال العمل
برؤيه الموحده فضلا عن الفوائد المرجوه
منها على المستوى الوطنيه
تاكيدها على سعيها الدؤوب للقيام بمشاريع
واحده من خلال هذه المبادره
لزياده المسطحات الخضراء من خلال التشديد
وزياده الغطاء النباتي
واقامه المحميات الطبيعيه
والاهتمام بالسياحه البيئيه
للمساهمه في الوصول الى الحياد الكربوني
خلال منتصف القرن الحالي
مما سيتوج باثر ايجابي في مجال البيئه
وخلق في راس اقتصاديه ضخمه تعود بالنفع
على الاجيال القادمه وفتح افاق جديده
لمستقبل اخبر المستدامه
الكويت الاعمال كامل لجهود شقيقتها الكبرى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بما يتفق عليه في ضوء امكانياتها ومواردها
ولم تدخل جدا او دعما
او امتثالا لتحقيق التوصيات التي تتوسل
اليها هذه المبادره بكافه سخيا
وختاما اكرره شكري لجميع القائمين على عقد
اعمال هذه القمه داعيا المولى العلي
القدير ان يهيئ لنا سبل الرشاد لتحقيق اما
نتطلع اليه جميعا من خير وتقدم وازدهار
لدولتنا والدول الشقيقه والصديقه والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر صاحب السمو الشيخ مشعل الصباح ولي
عهد دوله الكويت
اعطي الكلمه الان لفخامه رئيس الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الموريتانيه فخامه الرئيس محمد
ولد الشيخ الغزواني فليتفضل فخامته مشكوره
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
صاحب الفخامه عبد الفتاح السيسي رئيس
الجمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
صاحب السمو الملكي محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
صاحب السمو الملكي محمد بن سلمان ولي عهد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه رئيس
مجلس الوزراء وصاحب الفخامه عبد الفتاح
السيسي رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
للمشاركه في النسخه الثانيه من قمه الشرق
الاوسط
ان هذه المبادره
التي اطلقها سنه 2000 21 صاحب السمو
الملكي محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد مملكه
العربيه السعوديه رئيس مجلس الوزراء
تؤكد التزام المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولا شك ان الاجراءات المتخذ
التي هذه المبادره
علاوه علامات تسهم به من تاثير الايجابي
على البيئه
ستشكل دعما قويا لجهود القاره الافريقيه
في مواجهه التغيرات المناخيه
وانعكاساتها الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وعلى
وجه الخصوص الجهود التي تقوم بها
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الموريتانيه في هذا
الصدر والتي تترجمها مساهمه من الوطنيه
واننا اذا نوكدوا دعمنا بمبادره الشرق
الاوسط الاخضر
ولرؤيه الاستسقافيه الثاقبه التي
توجهها لنرجولها
ولمطلقها صاحب السمو الملكي محمد بن سلمان
ولي عهد المملكه العربيه السعوديه رئيس
مجلس الوزراء كل التوفيق والنجاح اشكركم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]
اشكرك فخامه الرئيس محمد ولد الشيخ
الغزواني على كلمته
الكلمه الان لسمو الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني ولي عهد المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه فليتفضل سموه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد
نبينا العربي الهاشمي
اصحاب الفخامه والسمومه السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته وبعد
بدايه نشكر جمهوريه مصر العربيه وفخامه
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي على استضافه
وتنظيم المؤتمر السابع والعشرين لتغير
المناخي
ونشكر مملكه العربيه السعوديه
والخادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز ال سعود و صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود على الاطلاق مبادرته الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر
لقد شارك الاردن في مختلف الاجتماعات
الفنيه الخاصه بهذه المبادره وذلك ايمانا
ايمانا منه باهميتها وموامتها لخططنا
واستراتيجياتنا الوطنيه
الهادفه الى زياده الرقعه الخضراء في
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه وتخفيف من اثار
التغير المناخي والحد من التصحر وتدهور
الاراضي
وعلى الرغم من التحديات التي تواجه
المملكه من قله الموارد المائيه والتي
تفاقمت نتيجه لاستقبالنا العديد من موجات
اللجوء خلال العقل الماضي الا اننا لم
نخفي الاهميه الحفاظ على البيئه
في خطوطنا واستراتيجياتنا الوطنيه
اذن الاقتصاد الاخضر والعمل المناخي جزء
لا يتجزا من من محركات النمو التي اطلقها
الاردن مؤخرا ضمن رؤيه التحديث الاقتصادي
للسنوات العشر القادمه
والتي ناس على تحقيقها من خلال شركات
فاعله بين انقطاعين العام والخاص محليا و
اقليميا ودوليا
وبشاركه الشباب والمراه
ما نامله اليوم هو السير القدماء في تنفيذ
هذه المبادره المهمه
التي نرى بانها ستكون نقطه الانطلاق لتبني
سياسات ومبادرات على مستويات الوطنيه
وختاما علينا ان نعمل معا لوضع السياسات
والبرامج والحلول المبتكره التي تكفل
مستقبلا اخضر ومستداما لهذا الجيل والا
الجهه القادمه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
اشكر صاحب السمو الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني
ولي عهد المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
الكلمه الان لدوله رئيسه الحكومه التونسيه
دوله الرئيس نجلاء بودن
شكرا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف المرسلين
فخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي رئيس
جمهوريه مصر العربيه
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
القائمه
اصحاب السمو الفخامه
منذ انعقاد القمه الاولى الى اليوم
شهد العالم تغيرات عميقه
فرضتها الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تفاقمت التحديات البيئيه
بينما المجموعه الدوليه
وانا هذه الخطه الفارغه في مصير الانسانيه
تستوجبه منا كمجموعه شرق الاوسط مزيدا من
تظافر الشهود من اجل تحقيق الاستجابه
للتوافي المستدام والاخضر والاخضر الشامل
وقد تم اقرار هذا التوجه الاستراتيجي في
برنامجنا الاصلاحي الوطني
والثنائي والاقليمي من خلال دعم دور
المراه ودور الشباب وتاهيل الكفاءات
وملائمه قدراتها مع مقتضيات وحاشيات
الاقتصاد الاخضر اضافه الى تبادل الخبرات
وتجارب
بناء الشركات في مجال البحوث والتجديد
والاستفاده من اليات التمويل الاخضر
المتاح
واعتمدنا الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه في افق 20
50 ده التنميه
منخفضه الكربون
والمتاقمه مع المتغيرات المناخيه لتكون
بمثابه خارطه الطريق للحد من جميع اشكال
الهشاشه وجعلي شهود
الكولوجي والفلاحي رافدا من روافد النمو
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي في مناطقنا الريفيه
والحضاريه وذلك وفقا لم تنويه
والفخامه ان اهداف مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر
تتطابق مع اهدافنا الوطنيه
الاستراتيجيه في تونس ولذلك
نجدد دعم تونس الكلي لها
وانخراطها فيها لتحقيق الاستفاده
المتبادله واستكشاف فرص التمويل المبتكر
المتاح ضمن هذه المبادره
وفقنا الله لما فيه خير وشعوبنا
واوطاننا والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[تصفيق]
الشكر لدوله الرئيس نجلاء بودن على
كلماتها
الكلمه الان
لدوله الرئيس محمد شهباز شريف
جمهوريه جمهوريه الباكستان الاسلاميه
فليتفضل مشكورا
باسم الرحمن الرحيم
اخواتي الاعزاء
سمو الامير ولي العهد محمد عبد محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز
صاحب الفخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
اصحاب المعالي والسمو والفخامه سيدتي
وسادتي السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان وفخامه الرئيس
عبد الفتاح السيسي
على تنظيم
الهامه للغايه نحن بالفعل نقدر تماما
الجهود
جهود سمو الامير محمد بن سلمان على هذه
المبادره الا وهي المبادره الاولى الخاصه
بالمنظومه البيئيه من نوعها في اقليم
الشرق الاوسط منطقه الشرق الاوسط ان هذا
الجهد غير المسبوق الرائع هو عباره عن
علامه فارقه
وتذكرنا جميعا
بقياداتك سمو الامير التي تصب الى
الحياه البشريه السليمه في هذه المنطقه
التي ياما في هذه العالم الذي يسعى جاهدا
لاتطلع الى مستقبلا متنوعان من حيث البيئه
وانا بالفعاله وثمن
اعمالك الرائعه وقيادتك ان الحلول مرتكزه
على الطبيعه
ايضا تقبع في
قلب طموحات بلدي واجنه بلدي حسب الاتفاقيه
واتفاقيه باريس
انا بالفعل مفعمه باهتمامك السليمه في
المبادره الخاصه بالارتلال الحلول المرتقي
من مرتكز على الطبيعه مثل
الغابات التي تبني قدره الدوله من حيث
التكيف وايضا
خفض انبعاثات الغازات الدفئه بالاضافه الى
الخفض من الاضرار والخسائر بسبب
تغير المناخ وذلك على المساواه الوطنيه
والمستويات الاقليميه
اصحى بالفخامه والمعالي والسمو اود ان
اذكر هنا واشير الى ان هدف امشي هي عباره
مرتكزه ومرتفقه تماما مع اهداف مع
سياسه باكستان للغابات وايضا برنامج
الاخضر الباكستاني الذي يركز على الحمايه
والاستفاده
واداره غابتنا والحياه البريه وذلك بحلول
عام 2030 وفي ظل هذا الوضع انا وثمن
جهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لاطلاق هذه المبادره الخضراء حيث انا
باكستان بالفعل تموت يدها من حيث التعاون
من حيث تبادل المعرفه ايضا توفير الخبراء
او تزويد غبره ان هذه مجرد البدايه ان
باكستان بالفعل تعرب عنا استعدادها التامه
وتقف على هبه الاستعداد لتعاون مع كل
البلدان الاعضاء في مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الخضراء وانت تشارك في تجارب
خبرات الفنيه المتعلقه
بالاستعاده الغابات وايضا المناطق
المناطق الخضراء او ايضا اداره المناطق
المحميه وايضا تقييم انبعاثات ثانيه اكسيد
الكربون وغيرهم همم ان الارض بالفعل
تدعونا للعمل ولكن يبدو اننا بالفعل ان
نتعلم ولكن بطريقه صعبه ان مبادره ميسي
الخضراء عباره عن احد الخطوات الكبيره
الرائعه في الاتجاه السليم باكستان تعرب
الالتزمها الكامل
اهداف لهذه المبادره وتتطلع للعمل عن كتب
في تعاون كتب مع كل البلدان الاعضاء وهذا
لا يقتصر فقط على هذه المبادره بل يمتد
ايضا في كل عمله للعمال الذي يدعو الى
حمايه الكوكب ضد تغيرات المناخ وشكرا
جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]
الشكر لدوله الرئيس محمد شهباز شريف على
كريمته
الكلمه لفخامه الرئيس اسماعيل عمر جليه
رئيس جمهوريه جيبوتي فليتفضل فخامته
مشكوره
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الانبياء وسيد
المرسلين محمد بن عبد الله وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين رحمه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء رئيس اللجنه العليا للسعوديه
الخضراء اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والصمود
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده الحضور والكرام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يسعدني في البدايه خالص الشكر وهو في
التقدير يا اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان عبد العزيز بن عبد العزيز
ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه والرئيس
المجلس اللجنه العليا للسعوديه الخضراء
ولاخي صاحب الفخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
على دعوتهم الكريمه للمشاركه في هذه القمه
الهامه
التي تنعبد بالتزامن مع الدوره السابعه
والعشرين لمؤتمر الامم المتحده
المعني بتغير المناخ كوب 27 كما يطيب لي
ان اهن جمهوريه مصر العربيه شقيقه على ما
بدلتهم من جهود المقدره في سبيل انجاح
القلمتين
المنعقدتين في شرم الشيخ علما بان مصر
كانت سباقه في تبني العديد من البرامج
والاستراتيجيات الناجحات في هذا المجال
الحيوي
المتمثل في
مكافحه التغير المناخ اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والصمود ان التغير المناخي يعتبر
من ابرز اخطر التحديات التي تواجه المنطقه
والعالم برمته والتي تزداد وتداعياتها
ثقافه تفاقما مع مرور الايام مما يستلزم
حشد الطاقات والموارد واذكار روح التعاون
الجماعي وتوحيد الجهود
للتصدي لتعلي لاثاره السلبيه التي تهدد
المستقبل البشري وفي هذه الصدد فاننا نجدد
تاكيد على اهميه البالغه التي يغتصبها
يكتسبها تحول الاخضر
لمواجهه التغير المناخ والذي ينطوي على
الانتقال الى النموذج التنموي الجديد يقوم
على الاقتصاد الاخضر والمنسد مع مفهوم
الاستدامه وتعزيز القدره
على الصمود والتكيف وحمايه البيئه ومن هنا
فان مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر التي
اطلقتها المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
في العام الماضي تحظى باهميه بالغه واننا
اذ نجدد شهاده بهذه المبادره الرائده التي
تشكل الرافدين مؤثرا
واضافه نوعيه للمساعي المبذوله في اطار
المعركه
العالميه ضد تغير المناخ فاننا ان نؤكد
ثقتنا لان اثرها الايجابي
سيطالع عموم المنطقه
وسيسهم في بناء مستقبل الاكثر استدامه
للاجيال القادمه سمو ولي العهد رئيس
اللجنه العليا السعوديه الخضراء صاحب
الفخامه الرئيس السيسي الحضور الكرام
النجمه الاولى اهتماما كبيرا لقضايا
البيئيه
والتغير المناخي في هذا السياره فان
جيبوتي لا تلوا جهدا في سبيل للحفاظ على
البيئه كما تحث الخطى نحو الاعتماد كليا
على مصادر الطاقه المتجدده في اطار رؤيتها
ونحن مفعمون بالتفاؤل والامل في ان نتمكن
من تحقيق هذا الهدف في القريب العجل
فان رؤيتنا بشان التعاطي مع القضايا
البيئيه
وتغير المناخ ترتكز على ضروره التضافر
الجهود الوطنيه
لهذه الظواهر على حياه البشريه وبالتالي
نحن ملتزمون بالانقراض في العمل الجماعي
ومواقبه المساعي المبذوله في هذا المضمار
على الصعيدين الاقليمي الدولي كما اننا لا
نتردد في القيام باي مبادره لا توجد بهذا
القصوص ومن الامثله الحيه على ذلك قيام
جيبوتي اواخر الشهر اكتوبر
دول دول منطقه القرن الافريقي والدول
الاخرى خارجيه وقد كان من ضمن انفعاليات
هذه القمه التي اجمع على المشاركون فيها
على انها جاءت في وقتها لحاجه الاقليم
لمثل هذه المبادرات
بيبقى بحوث البيئيه والمناخ
واعكس ذلك كله رغبه الجلوس الاخيره في
الوفاء
بالتزاماتها تجاه قضيه المناخ التي تمس
الوجود الانساني قبل كل شيء
جددوا الاعراب عن الشهاده
بالدور القيادي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه في مواجهه التغير المناخي
والتعامل مع اثاره ولعلق خير الدليل على
ذلك
واجتماعنا اليوم في اطار النسخه الثانيه
لقمه شرق الاوسط الاخضر التي تاتي
استكمالا للنجاح الذي
حققته القبه الاولى
كماري كل الجمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
رئاستها لكوكب 27
لقب 27
لعمل المناخ الدولي خلال الفتره المقبله
ستكون ناجحه وتحقق الاهداف المرسوم
وانطلاقا من ايماننا باهميه العمل
التشاركيه لمواجهه التحديات البيئيه فانني
اود ان اؤكده على استعداد جيبوتي التام
للعمل بشكل الوثيق مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه وجمهوريه مصر العربيه
الشقيقه في هذا الصبر ونسال الله العلي
القدير ان يوفقنا لما فيه الخير والصلاح
وشكرا والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]
الشكر لفخامه الرئيس اسماعيل عمر جليه على
كلمته
الكلمه الان لفخامه رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في جمهوريه السودان فخامه
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان فليتفضل
فخامه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله الصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
فخامه السيد الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه صاحب
السمو الملكيه الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي
العهد والرئيس مجلس الوزراء بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه شقيقه ساده اصحاب الجلال
والفخامه والمعاليل رؤساء الدول والحكومات
والرسائل وجود حضور جميعا سلام عليكم
ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
اولا يسمى جهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه في التصدي الجاد لا يسار
المتغيرات المناخيه في منطقتنا
ونحسب ان مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
نسختها السابقه والراهنه والقادمه هي
الاهليه العلميه
والعمليه المناسبه لامتصاص ومعالجه الاثار
السالبه
في التغيرات المناخيه وصيانه البيئه
ايضا معالجه تدهور التربه والمحافظه على
الغطاء الغربي والمراعي الطبيعيه
والتنوع الحيوي ومن هنا نجدد تاكيد
السودان على الانقراض في برامج ومشروعات
هذه المبادره
كما نكت على اتاحه كل امكانيات السودان
الطبيعيه من الاراضي والمياه لتنفيذ خطب
ومشروعات هذه المبادره ذات الفائده
العابره لدول وشعوب المنطقه حضور الكريم
لا يشفعني في الختام الا نجدد التزام
السودان وخطب وبرامج التحول الاخضر ويتاحه
امكانيات السودان وموارد الطبيعيه لتكون
تحت التصرف اليه التحول الاخضر الشكر كل
الشكر للمملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والشكر لجمهوريه مصر العربيه الشهيره
والشكر لله ما انساهم في نجاح مبادره
التحول الاخضر والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]
الشكر لفخامه الرئيس الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان على كلماته
الكلمه الان لفخامه رئيس مجلس القياده
الرئاسي في الجمهوريه اليمنيه
فخامه الرئيس الدكتور رشاد العليمي
فليتفضل فخامتهم مشكوره
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب الفخامه الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي رئيس جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
اصحاب الفخامه والسمو المعالي والسعاده
سيدات والساده السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
اليوم هذا الاجتماع بمناسبه انطلاق مبادره
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر التي تعدوا اساما
فاعلا من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه للتخفيف من حراره كوكبنا والتقليل
من الاثار السلبيه للتغيرات المناخيه هذه
المبادره تمثل منصه للتعاون الاقليمي
لتعزيز الحفاظ على الغطاء النباتي ودعم
الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه التي تهدف الى
خلق فرصه تعاونا بينيه تتعدى الحدود وتعزز
فرص السلام والتنميه بين شعوب المنطقه
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده سيدات والساده
الدنيا على ثقه بان هذه المبادره
ستعززوا من فرص التعاون البيت
وتبني جسور العلاقه مع كافه المنظمات
الدوليه المعنيه وستكون منصه لنقل الخبرات
والتجارب بحمايه البيئه وستعمل على تشجيع
الابتكار وتنفيذ الحلول القائمه على
الطبيعه للحد من تدهور الاراضي والمساهمه
في تحقيق اهداف التنميه المستدامه على
الصعيد الوطني
من هذه المبادره ان تساعد بلادنا على
اعاده تاهيل نظم التنوع الحيوي والنباتي
الاراضي والغابات والقطار الاخضر الذي
تعرض للتدهور جراء الحرب التي شنتها
الميليشيات الارهابيه الحوثيين المدعومه
من النظام الايراني والتي احرقت الارض
والنسل من خلال زراعه مئات الالاف من
الالغام البريه والبحريه وقطعت الاشجار
وهجرت السكان مما شكل ضغطا اضافيا على
التنوع الحيوي بشكل عام والنباتي بشكل خاص
نحن اليوم نبارك للاشقاء في مصر نجاح قمه
المناخ كما نبارك للاشقاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انطلاق هذه المبادره
بنسقتها الثانيه
وهذا يدعونا
للفخر بان بلداننا العربيه صارت تمتلك
زماما المبادرات لاحداث تحولات فاعله
تساهم في تعافي كوكب الارض ختاما اتمنى
للمبادره النجاح وتحقيق اهدافها واني على
ثقه بان هذه المبادره هي في الاصل مبادره
نجاح وجد تستمر لانها تمثل السلام والامن
والمحبه والنون والشجره هي رمز الحياه
والسلام وسنعمل معا مع الشقيقه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبقيه شعوب المنطقه
لانجاح هذه المبادره المهمه لتكون نموذجا
للتعاون والعمل البيني والانساني وفقنا
الله جميعا بما فيه خير بلداننا وشعوب
الانسانيه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته